there's a huge amount of videos coming
out because of the scale of Devastation
we're going to be taking a forensic look
at them in the search and rescue effort
with AB from serve on so what we want to
show you is some of the extent of the
damage by looking at what it was before
this is a skender and it's a city uh in
the southwest of Port City and this is
what it looked like before the
earthquake start I want to take you into
Google Street View here in the middle of
the city more or less you can see it is
a built up place
um but we need to focus on a couple of
buildings here this distinctive uh
skyscraper there this Tower block there
um and then if you look over here we've
got this apartment block now this is
what it looks like after the earthquake
start we can play that video you can see
those are the three tower blocks and
that block simply doesn't exist anymore
as the video goes on you'll see go
further to the right again that was the
apartment block we saw before when
you're looking at this and you see a
city-wide Devastation like this how do
you approach it is there sort of triage
process to it triage is the right way to
put it if you imagine there's maybe 10
or 15 teams on the ground how do we
organize where they go so we've got to
look at the about the buildings and and
as you said some buildings have
collapsed and some haven't and it could
be right or right the way across the
city so we need to figure out which
buildings have got the most likelihood
of finding casualties in them when you
mentioned that that some buildings
collapse and some don't this is a video
from another part of turkey it's not the
same city but we look through this
you'll see these buildings are standing
and then over here that's coming down as
the rescue effort is ongoing I think
people watch them think why is that
building completely fine and why is this
building coming down
there's a number of reasons why why that
can happen one obviously is just pure
luck there's there's no way we can be
predictable about an earthquake or where
or where it's going to hit it doesn't
always hit the whole area
um it could be luck it could be down to
um the quality of the building and
actually it could even be that one
building was was holding up another
building so when one goes the other
one's still the domino effect I think
the quality of the building I mean
that's obviously going to be something
people focus on afterwards and where and
whether those standards were met but
just in the here and now you know this
is the search and rescue effort you're
shortly going to Turkey you're going to
be taking part in this when you're going
out there and you come across these
scenes if you're there on the scene what
are the first things you're thinking
about as a rescue worker with the rescue
worker the first thing that we think
about is is speed of getting of
casualties out
um they could have been in there for 15
or 16 hours by the time we get we by the
time we get to them so it's how do we
get them out but how do we get them out
safely you can see all of these uh
volunteers uh helping out here we must
make sure that that we're not putting
them in any in any further danger and
how do we get the casualty out without
putting them in any further further
danger either AB from servon thank you
very much best of luck in Turkey from
all of us there's going to be lots more
videos coming out given the scale of the
devastation we'll be working to verify
them analyze them forensically bringing
the latest over the coming days